diez años después del primer discurso
del estado de la unión pronunciado por
josé manuel barroso la alemana ursula
von der leyen se presentó frente a la
asamblea en un contexto particularmente
tenso para la entidad europea la
presidenta a cargo desde hace nueve
meses dijo que los ciudadanos europeos
han mostrado fuerza de espíritu durante
la pandemia y rindió un homenaje a los
trabajadores esenciales sanitarios y en
primera línea de la lucha contra el
virus por lo tanto llamó a los
dirigentes a que el bloque mejore su
respuesta a los acontecimientos que se
desarrollan en todo el mundo von der
leyen presentó su visión de una nueva
unión europea que salga de la crisis del
coronavirus sofom y el gris eso creo
para mí está claro como el agua
necesitamos construir una unión europea
de la salud más fuerte es hora de
hacerlo pero está en su lugar
el break si también tuvo protagonismo en
la cita política la máxima autoridad
europea advirtió a londres que el bloque
nunca dará marcha atrás en el acuerdo de
divorcio de reino unido ante song we
must be one y faith partes este acuerdo
ha sido ratificado por esta cámara y por
la cámara de los comunes no puede ser
cambiado unilateralmente ignorado o
desaprobado es una cuestión de ley
confianza y de buena fe y hahndorf es
otro tema relevante la cuestión del
cambio climático la jefa de la comisión
propuso aumentar el objetivo de
reducción de los gases de efecto
invernadero en un 55 por ciento con
respecto a las cifras de 1990 para
alcanzar la neutralidad de carbono en
2050 actualmente el objetivo está en un
40 por ciento de reducción